okay so this is the day one confessional
lecture ended a couple hours ago just
been trying to do the homework
assignment on with the students holy cow
it is really exhausting to teach and
three hour three hours goes by way
faster when you're talking it does when
you are listening um I think overall it
could have definitely been a lot more
catastrophic than it was so that's
always good I think the hardest thing
was just getting people to be engaged in
discussion it was just there just so
quiet overall it was just hard to get
them engaged in discussion Jamie was
awesome but it's fine because she's
taught middle school so she clearly has
a very good handle I'm facilitating
these kind of things once she got people
to talk at some of the stuff that they
were saying was great at the
conversations that they were having
about their experiences with online
video I'm really glad that she prodded
them a little bit more whereas I just
wanted to give up after no one said
anything we have a time goes by really
fast is definitely pressed for time
which shouldn't have surprised me but
still did and just making sure to leave
breathing room for students i mean i did
try to pace off the video stuff so that
they'd have sort of a breather from
hearing someone just talk to them for
three hours and but i do feel like it
was just a super-dense lecture today I
think passing it off with Chris at the
end helped a lot but I would have liked
to had more time to just have students
get up and use the cameras and maybe
work on the stem videos during class I
know a teacher who teaches high school
sociology and his philosophy is just
like stay one step back one day ahead on
this syllabus from the glass and I've
been feeling a little bit like that in
terms of the materials but maybe it's
just the adrenaline from day one but I
do feel like it was okay a little
nervous for tomorrow with all the sixth
graders a lot nervous about tomorrow but
I have already met the kids and their
kids just a matter of trying to balance
everything I need to do for work aside
from lecture now I get it now I now I
get why why professors don't always want
to prioritize lecturing so they don't
want to thats there just aren't enough
hours in the day i'm going to sleep like
a rock tonight